Remember that the circumference is the
length around the outside of a circle.
So that's this blue line here.
And the diameter is the length of a line
that passes through the center of
the circle and
whose endpoints lie on the circle.
So this line here.
You can also think about this
as the width of the circle.
This should not be
confused with the radius
which is the length of a line from the
center of the circle to the perimeter.
It's important to note that the radius
is half the length of the diameter or
the diameter is twice
the length of the radius.
There is a relationship between
circumference and diameter.
Pi links them.
We can find the circumference C of any
circle using C = Pi times diameter D.
Since diameter is
the same thing as twice
the radius this can also
be written as c = 2 pi r